après l'unef c'est au tour d'audrey
pulvar de faire scandale avec les
réunions en non-mixité sa raciale selon
la candidate ps à la région
ile-de-france on peut aussi demander aux
blancs de se taire déclaration qui à
nouveau fait couler beaucoup d'encre et
créer une fracture politique alors les
blancs doivent-ils se taire pour
reprendre les mots d'audrey pulvar c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en débattre nous sommes en direct
avec julien oudoul membre du bureau
national du rassemblement national
conseiller municipal de sens et candidat
aux régionales de juin 2021 ou région
bourgogne franche comté bonsoir julien
odoul à vos côtés david guiraud
porte-parole jeunesse de la france
insoumise bonsoir des libéraux merci à
vous aussi d'être là alors demandé aux
blancs de se taire en cas de
participation à une réunion non mixtes
sait ce qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette déclaration julien aux boules
maladresse provocation ou racisme à
l'envers
bah écoutez si on avait la situation
inverse
si un élu du rassemblement national ou
un élu de droite avait dit que dans une
réunion
je dirais de victimes de l'insécurité de
victimes du terrorisme dans ces réunions
les noirs devaient se taire ou les
personnes d'origine maghrébine devaient
se taire ça aurait fait un tollé
légitimement légitimement toute la
classe politique médiatrice se serait
insurgés et aurait condamné cette
personne parce que c'est du racisme est
là parce que c'est madame pulvar parce
que encore une fois il ya des
complaisances d'une certaine gauche
parce qu'elle est complaisance
médiatique on parle de maladresses mais
excusez moi de dire à des noirs de se
taire ou de dire à des blancs de se
taire ou exclure des blancs ou des noirs
de réunions parce qu'ils sont pas les
bienvenus c'est du racisme et ça n'a
rien à voir avec la république française
la république française ne reconnaît que
trois couleurs le bleu le blanc et le
rouge
elle ne distingue les citoyens que par
leur mérite
elle ne distingue pas le citoyen en
fonction de leur origine de leur race ou
de leur religion
donc je trouve ça extrêmement grave
évidemment que c'est une phrase raciste
de la part d' audrey pulvar et ça
devrait
je dirais suscité les condamnations
unanimes il peut pas y avoir deux poids
deux mesures le racisme
vous savez il est universel il ya des
formes de racisme divers et variés
malheureusement c'est comme la bêtise
ben laden
malheureusement on trouve partout il ya
du racisme anti noir il ya du racisme
anti blanc il ya du racisme anti
asiatique dont on parle très peu
d'ailleurs et c'est bien malheureux mais
il faut les condamner avec la même force
et avec la même fermeté
et là malheureusement on constate qu' il
ya une forme de complaisance ou une
forme de relativisme
voilà on peut tolérer que dans certaines
réunions balle et blanc doivent se taire
on peut tolérer que dans certaines
réunions les blancs soient exclus c'est
anti anti républicain intolérable et
inadmissible on va faire évidemment
david guiraud mais les avants cela pour
répondre quelque sorte aussi à votre
remarque
il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de réactions au
niveau du ps jean luc mélenchon a
justement pris la défense de dre pulvar
écouter audrey pulvar n'est pas raciste
elle a juste compris ce qu'est un groupe
de parole ceux qui se jettent sur elle
par contre n'arrive pas à cacher leur
pente sexistes et discriminante
le débat public s'effondre le ps va-t-il
défendre sa candidate en ile-de-france
un délit de guerre on voit une
différence de vision radicale
effectivement entre le rnd et la france
insoumise audrey pulvar en aucun cas
racisme pas de complaisance à gauche non
mais c'est trop drôle enfin franchement
moi je ça me fait rire quoi donc julien
odoul en fait il en train de nous dire
que le rassemblement national c'est une
organisation anti-raciste qu'il faut pas
faire le tri entre le personne noire ou
arabe blanche juive alors qu'il n'y a
même pas un mois il soutenait une
organisation génération identitaire
kapoor concept le celui de la raf tueur
qui a pour concept et comme doctrine
politique de virer les noirs et les
arabes et tous ceux qui sont pas
français soit disant de souche pure
parce que ça même pas de souchez de
souche pure du pays dont des porte
parole explique qu'il faut que les
choses soient renvoyés l'heure mais même
si ils sont là en france depuis le
xiième siècle c'était monsieur pierre
l'artiste est pas faux c'est un fait
avéré et il nous fait des leçons
d'antiracisme
donc moi je me demande juste à quel
moment va finir la blague en fait parce
que la blague aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
est quand même en face moi j'ai en face
d'une organisation dont la présidente
marine le pen a été la porte parole d'un
homme qui disait que les chambres à gaz
étaient un détail de l'histoire
ces gens là vont nous donner des leçons
d'antiracisme à quel moment est-ce qu'on
a glissé dans la perception des choses
pour qu'on en arrive à la moi je pose
juste la question parce que julien houle
en ce moment il nous donne des grandes
leçons mais je sais pas si si si le but
c'est de vouloir participer à des
réunions à laquelle par ailleurs il ne
va jamais à quel moment le rassemblement
national a fait des réunions sur
l'antiracisme
à quel moment donc pourquoi ces gens là
veulent aller à des réunions d'automne
par rapport à lesquels qu'ils en ont
rien à faire en temps habituel vous
voyez bien qu'à une supercherie qui font
qu'on peut pas commencer à plonger dans
dans des polémiques qui sont des
polémiques d'extrême droite par ailleurs
je tiens à faire remarquer mais ça à la
limite c'est même pas la faute du
rassemblement national plutôt celle du
gouvernement que j'ai des positions bien
plus dur que madame pulvar sur les
réunions non mixtes ya jamais eu une
seule polémique nationale qui a été
lancée à cause de ça au bout d'un moment
faudra aussi se demander pourquoi c'est
mélanie luce et audrey pulvar de femmes
noires sur qui on tombe et pas sur des
militants qui pourtant sont bien plus
énervé qu'elle sur ces sujets comme moi
quoi il y aurait un certain sexisme
zunien odoul qu'est ce que vous répondez
à david guiraud
il ya beaucoup de choses à répondre
c'est que monsieur guiraud comme ses
petits copains et petits camarades de la
france insoumis sont des obsédés de la
race ce sont des racialiste les obsédés
des couleurs voilà qui divise en
permanence qui classe les gens en
fonction de leur origine de leur
appartenance et monsieur guiraud qui me
parle vous faites jamais de réunions
contre le racisme et où on a pas besoin
d'en faire nous nous monsieur on n'a pas
besoin d'en faire ce que nous le
programme de marine le pen
il est foncièrement naturellement et
évidemment anti raciste parce que c'est
un programme rassemblement national
parce que c'est parce que c'est le
programme en fait qui s'affirme on ne
voit que disent ils ne voient que des
citoyens français
vous savez moi ça ne m'intéressera je
n'ai je n'ai jamais vu les couleurs des
gens moi ça ne m'intéresse pas ce qu'ils
sont moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce
qu'ils font voilà c'est toute la
différence bien sûr entre vous et nous
parce que vous vous êtes toujours dans
l'essentialisme mais toujours à reléguer
les personnes je vais terminer reléguer
les personnes en fonction de leur
couleur de leur origine pour attiser la
haine
heureux sont sous notre projet à nous le
projet de marine le pen c'est un projet
de réconciliation avec la sono on nous
on ne voit que des français vous
comprenez ça on ne voit que des français
c'est tout ce qui nous importe
et quand il avait ce genre de l'émotion
quand vous avez un jour de l'an dans pau
qui a laissé mourir peur de quoi
question qui exclut des citoyens en
fonction de la communion de leur peau
c'est extrêmement grave
c'est extrêmement grave et ça devrait
être condamnée d'accord donc évidemment
vous êtes en marge de la réglisse une
fois la parole est à vous oui
effectivement le rmt qui y voit là qui
accuse l'escaladent racistes de la part
d'une partie de l'extrême gauche à vous
répondez quoi c'est marine le pen qui le
dit à julien ou double ce soir
non mais évidemment c'est limpide que
leurs ailes rassemblement national est
pas une organisation truffé de gens
racistes et antisémites je pense à
damien rieu qui a un ancien leader de
génération identitaire que vous venez
d'investir dans les départementales dans
d'autres sélections départementales fait
dès l'épreuve
monsieur d'époque mais j'en ai beaucoup
quand on envahit des mosquées ou quand
on fait comme vous vous dites que vous
voyez pas les couleurs des gens mais par
contre humilié une femme voilée une
femme qui porte le foulard dans un
conseil départemental
j'imagine que vous avez lu quelque chose
quand même c'est qu'elle était infondée
et je ne veux dire une chose monsieur
quand vous avez pas parler j'aimerais
finir maintenant
maintenant c'est à moi de parler
monsieur n'ayez pas peur des faits
d'armes il est à dire que vous défendez
les français parce que vous savez vous
savez ce qui est pire là dedans
vous savez le pire là dedans c'est pas
votre c'est pas votre fantasme sur le
fait que vous êtes anti racistes à faire
ce n'y croit c'est évident que leur
assemblée nationale est une organisation
rempli gioria la france est grave là
dedans c'est que vous dites que vous
faites ça oui bah justement les français
sur trois mois j'aimerais en parler de
ces foncé sur 3 vous en parlait pas
beaucoup mais c'est français parce que
quand vous êtes mise en responsabilité
quand vous êtes dans des mairies
monsieur au double je vous rappelle que
ce que vous faites c'est vous en prenez
y compris aux français blancs parce que
monter votre mairie la supprimer la
gratuité de la cantine à villers
cotterêts que nous allions de lentilles
pour les plus pauvres à mantes la ville
votre premier rassemblement national oil
peut-être un peu du débat et ça va ça va
être la france insoumise contre le rn et
on voudrait on vous remettra pas
d'accord mais est ce que quand même pu
penser que c'est justement parce qu'on
est blanc on doit se taire dans une
réunion pour revenir à l'essence de
notre débat dans une question oui mais
l'essence de notre débat c'est qu'il ya
des gens aujourd'hui qui prétendent
utiliser ce débat ans 10 anti racistes
paraît pensant comme s'ils défendent les
gens qui sont blancs et pas alors qu'en
vérité qu'en vérité même les blancs et
les classes pour les guerres qui sont
blanches de ce pays vous n'êtes pas
journaliste vont donc j'ai pas de
comptes à bourran monsieur monsieur même
les gens qui sont allés pour les terres
de ce pays vous n'avez pas encore le
pouvoir donc calme et vous vous vous en
prenez cet accord à mantes-la-ville vous
mettez la fin vous mettez fin à la
gratuité des activités périscolaires
mais au pontet vous mettez pas au
téléthon à hénin beaumont et vous
interdisez le marché de noël j'ai deux
fausses couches populaires les c'est ça
votre stratégie
c'est qu'en vérité est ce que vous aimez
pas les pauvres et que souvent les
pauvres ils sont noirs et war avec ça
vous démange là mais bon ça ne voulait
pas répond que je vais je vais vous
faire rebondir sur sur un saut important
puisque c'est valérie pécresse puisque
je vous l'appel à audrey pulvar est la
candidate ps aux régionales en île de
france et donc futur adversaire ne
valérie pécresse est ce que le parti
socialiste ou non doit lui faire retirer
son investiture déjà écouté valérie
pécresse
je crois à l'indivisibilité de la
république et à l'unité de la nation
dans ma région aucun habitant ne doit
être discriminé pour la couleur de sa
peau
il n'y a pas de racisme acceptable je
serai toujours un rempart face à ceux
qui tentent de fracture et notre pays un
mot chacun s'il vous plaît messieurs
julien audy est ce que le parti
socialiste doit retirer l investiture
d'audrey pulvar en tout cas ce serait
bien qu'on entend de madame anne hidalgo
sur les comportements et sur la
formulation de sa de son adjointe madame
pulvar
parce que c'est vrai qu'on l'entend pas
madame hidalgo on voudrait savoir ce
qu'elle cautionne le racisme et le
racialisme de madame pulvar c'est très
intéressant et c'est vrai que pour le
débat des régionales en île de france
on voit bien que avec les candidatures
communautariste racialiste ya un
candidat qui est le celui du front
républicain qui est jordan bardella
aujourd'hui le candidat de la république
le candidat encore une fois
de la citoyenneté de la sécurité et de
légalité de l'égalité de tous les
franciliens
quelle que soit la couleur de leur peau
quelle que soit leur origine quelle que
soit leur religion
c'est jordan bardella donc j'invite tout
le monde dehors de citoyens de la rn la
france insoumise restons dans les
questions s'il vous plaît dernière
question avoue david garros il paie est
sanctionné audrey pulvar pour ça pour
l'instant pas trop de réactions du côté
des socialistes est ce que vous vous
seriez prêt à l'accueillir
bien sûr mais vous savez ce qui est
drôle dans ce que dit julien au bout de
sept mois j'attends juste qu'il fasse du
stand-up ans parce que ça devient
vraiment comique en cette position sur
sur sur l'antiracisme
mais effectivement par contre il ya une
chose qui est vraie première c'est que
le parti socialiste est bien silencieux
et que je trouve qu'il ya pour le coup
pour le coup et une demande de carte et
voilà et une demande de cartes et autres
ceux qui défendent les antiracistes et
ceux qui veulent les censurer je suis
pas d'accord avec monsieur oudoul sur la
sur l'a10 sur la conclusion que le ps
doit en tirer
mais il ya un moment faut que ces gens
prennent un peu de courage parce que
c'est pas normal de rester silencieux
comme ça c'est leur candidate 1 enfin
rendez vous compte quand même
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une organisation
politique qui ne soutient pas sa
candidate dans la région la plus peuplée
et la plus riche du pays
on en est là aujourd'hui il ya une
lâcheté à gauche moi je n'ai pas peur de
le dire moi je trouve qu'il ya une
lâcheté à gauche parce que le
rassemblement national c'est normal ils
sont sur leurs thématiques raciste bon
généreux double essaye de nous de nous
faire du patinage sur glace là en ce
moment c est à un niveau artistique pour
nous faire croire que c'est pas une
organisation qui sort sur le racisme
mais il ya une demande de clarté dans le
pays effectivement et moi vous savez à
la france est soumise on défend les
antiracistes pour moi ce qui ce qui est
grave dans le pays c'est le racisme
c'est pas les antiracistes donc
effectivement doit y avoir ce débat et
je trouve ça bien dommage de la part du
parti socialiste qui soit aussi
silencieux la première condition de
l'unité vous savez à gauche on en parle
souvent de l'unita gauche
la première condition c'est celle du
combat politique et de mener des combats
communs aujourd'hui l'iran n'est pas
parce qu'on arrive à la fin du débat
vous n'avez toujours pas répondu à ma
question pardonnez moi mais vous vous
pensez alors qu'elle que les blancs une
doivent se taire dans certaines réunions
quand même c'est intéressant qu'on
connaisse votre position précise
convaincre sur ce sujet et sans faire
des longs discours ce qu'on arrive à la
fin de notre débat ah bah faut savoir
mais non mais il ya des franchement la
formulation je la trouve pas top mais la
question aujourd'hui c'est que pourquoi
est ce qu est ce que vous avez le
sentiment de ferme moi je ne suis pas su
saisir
je me sens pas fragile vous voyez au
point de me dire que si je ne suis pas
une réunion ma parole va manquer au
monde entier voilà je vous le dis il ya
des réunions en ce moment où des femmes
par exemple parle de viol elle parle de
violences sexuelles
vous avez des organisations comme des
étudiants juifs de france qui se sont
formés dans le pays parce qu'il ya un
moment en fait l'antisémitisme dont sont
issus notamment certains membres dieu du
rassemblement national parce que les
fondateurs c'était des waffen ss pour
certains mais c'est dans les étudiants
juifs ou ressenti le besoin de
s'organiser entend défendre dans le celi
et c'est tout à fait un bond énorme
pressing f1 estime déroute essuyée
lancer des noirs et des arabes
c'est ce fait les islamistes tourner la
question ont concédé noirs et des arabes
voilà quand c'était encore fait pour
monsieur guy roux pas concéder l'anc
doivent se tait pas quand c'est les
jeunes ouvriront les blancs doivent se
taire bravo merci merci julien oddo
merci à david guiraud d'avoir été avec
nous et d'avoir à vous vous devriez vous
percevrez bon j'ai continué à parler le
pays via durer combien on va vous
remettre ensemble en face à face comme
ça au moins vous vous ne voudrez pas
ensemble merci beaucoup à tous les deux